evan carmichael
evan carmichael believe this guy
is a force of nature he is a
nuclear-powered
professional he's flown from toronto
and you probably think that he's here to
speak about social media
and you're wrong he is here
to dance salsa
he really is and he invited me out
tonight to
dance also but i expect that we're going
to have separate partners right
95 of businesses
should not be spending money on social
media advertising
let me say that again 95 of you guys
should not be spending any money
on your social media campaigns on the
advertising side
the problem is advertising improves
already existing successful campaigns
and the problem is your current
campaigns aren't good enough
your current campaigns suck and so
throwing advertising dollars on top of
it is not going to help you
i like to think of campaigns as
franchises
so if you're going to start a restaurant
and you want to franchise it out
you have to have one location be
successful first
right you can't franchise if your one
location doesn't work
i like to think of it as a fire so your
successful social media campaign
is your fire and advertising is the
gasoline on top of it
advertising can make your campaign
explode it can make it go to
new heights but you have to have the
fire
if you pour gasoline on nothing you're
not going to get a huge spark
right you need to have the fire and
that's having a quality social media
campaign
your campaigns aren't good enough yet i
also believe
that you can build a huge fire you can
build a forest fire
without any advertising just by having a
really good quality campaign something
that you can be proud of
something that you believe in if the
conditions are there
if you're standing for something
important you don't even need the
advertising to help you grow
this hopefully is not you today during
my presentation
this is most of your campaigns
they're boring they put people to sleep
they suck that's mostly your campaigns
that's 95
of the campaigns out there they suck
think about what you're putting out
there are you actually proud of it
is there any feeling behind it would you
retweet your tweets if it wasn't you
if it wasn't your company would you
share this stuff
probably not and that's the problem
that's the problem with your campaigns
right now you throw advertising on top
of this nothing's gonna happen
you have to make your campaigns better
the key thing to think about is how many
people are actually sharing your stuff
whatever you put up right now you have a
little bit of a following
twitter facebook whatever you're using
you have a little bit of a following are
people
actually sharing your stuff
even though you have a small sample size
do they care enough to share it
because if they don't throwing
advertising dollars is not going to do
anything for you
you have to produce something that you
are proud of this is an example of a
video i launched
a month ago the slides a couple days old
in one
month we made this video we put it live
on youtube
it now has almost 160 000 views
it has what 2 000 thumbs ups 200 plus
comments
i did zero advertising for this zero
advertising
it took off because it's a really good
campaign
you watch this video and for those of
you who are sitting on my thursday
session i'm gonna be playing this video
live you watch this video and you feel
something
and that makes you want to share it your
campaigns have to be this
good they have to be something that when
people see it
they want to share it i could throw
advertisers on top of this
and make it explode but it's already
trending pretty well right now
i come from the school where money is
important okay i'm the founder of my own
business
my very first company i was 19 years old
a software company i was struggling to
make anything i was making 300
a a month 300 american dollars
per month that's what i was pulling out
you can't survive on that right i was
eating beans for lunch every day
to make my company grow money is
important
when i invest dollars in something it
has to work
if you come from the school where you
have tons of budget you got you know
some big partners supporting you you
have lots of money to spend on
advertising and go for it
but if you come from the school where
money is really tight
when you invest something it has to work
then your dollars especially at the
beginning are better spent creating an
amazing campaign something
that means something instead of
advertising
martin luther king he got 250
000 people to come to washington dc with
him
in 1963 to talk about equal rights
for black people in america 250
000 people how did he do that he didn't
have a twitter account
he didn't have a newsletter he wasn't
posting blogs there was no youtube
and yet 250 000 people came out to see
him speak
why because he had an important message
because he stood for something because
when you listen to him speak it made you
feel something
and this is what's missing in all of
your campaigns
people don't feel anything reading your
tweets about a promotional coupon you
have
or the latest blog posts you wrote they
don't care you have to make them feel
something and that comes from you
standing for something important when
you figure that out
then you can create a great campaign and
then you can throw advertising on top of
it and it'll explode on you
but this is a step that you're all
missing this is a step most people are
missing
you're just spamming stuff out there you
have to stand for something important
so what do you stand for what i want to
do
is have you guys pick one word one word
that defines who you are
you have your one word biography this is
what you stand for this is the positive
change
that you want to make in the world one
word
and when you figure out what that one
word is that becomes a theme for your
entire social media campaign
i'm going to give you some examples
martin luther king stood for equality
right and the people who have a lot of
success you can you can sum them up in
one word because it's easy to spread
their message
nelson mandela stood for freedom oprah
winfrey
heart steve jobs innovation you guys all
know him
this guy is incredible
he is a consummate entertainer
unbelief and for me this isn't a
marketing thing okay this isn't coming
up with a marketing slogan for your
company
this is a personal positioning statement
this is your personal branding
everything i do is about belief this
isn't just what i'm positioning myself
as a company
i believe in entrepreneurs
i can't help it it's who i am and so
whatever company i bring it to whatever
social media campaign i launch
has to incorporate believe and i sell
a lot of programs and seminars and
worksheets
and advertising and sponsorships but if
you read my twitter and and
facebook and all the social media
channels it's never
a pitch because you have to get people
to feel something
before they're going to take action if
they don't feel anything with your
business
and what you're putting out there you're
not going to get any results you're
going to be sitting there saying why
aren't people
sharing this stuff this is going to be
right now
the most important exercise that you
ever do with your business
we're going to find your one word today
right now there is one word
that strings together your entire life
okay
think about the books that you like to
read
your friends the people who who are in
your life who you enjoy their company
the movies you like to watch the songs
you listen to the companies you've
worked at or founded the jobs you've had
the quotes you like to read the art you
like to look at and consume
there's one word that strings them all
together
you have to figure that out for me it's
belief
i read books that are about belief i
like reading books about people
who have come from nothing and become
something they overcame huge odds
the friends that i have believe and
believe
the movies that i watch are about
believe you know my favorite movie
i like the jobs movie you guys have seen
jobs it's a great movie you haven't go
check it out
i like seabiscuit do you guys know
seabiscuit maybe about the horse
why has nothing to do with
entrepreneurship has nothing to do with
business
why do i like this movie so much because
it's about the little guy you know like
the horse everybody gave up on
and he made it through all the the
struggles and
and the the pain he made it
the companies i founded the quotes i
like to read are all about beliefs so i
challenge you today to think about what
that one word is
in your life and we're throwing up a new
hashtag
msmw the number one word i want you to
put it up
right now so you can see what people are
doing i can't see it on the screen
but i see a few passion
can't read it i need to work on my
glasses i need to get some better vision
i want you to put it up there right now
though guys this is important this
becomes a foundation
for all of your social media campaigns
for everything you do in business it's
not just social media
your company has to stand something
stand for something that has to make
people feel
you have to get people to feel something
to have an emotional connection
to your brand before they're going to
take any action
think about nike okay nike in their
commercials and their advertisement in
in all of their positioning
they don't compare themselves to reebok
they don't talk about
how their shoe was better than reebok or
better than puma or whatever other
company
what does nike do they talk about
athletics
they'll throw up a picture of lebron
james because when you put on a nike
shoe
you feel like you're a champion that's
the feeling that they get out there
you have to make people feel something
with your business first
you may not have your one word right now
okay i see some of them kind of
streaming in
you may not have your one word all
figured out right now but this is such
an important exercise guys
because when you're thinking of founding
your next company we're thinking of
bringing on people on your team
when you're thinking about launching
your book we're thinking about
creating a social media campaign it has
to embody this feeling
until you do that it's hopeless it's
lost your campaign isn't going to go
anywhere
so make people feel something first
and that sets up your campaign for
success
on thursday i'm going to be breaking
this down a little more detail i've got
you know 15 minutes today to try to hit
you with something
there's a five-step process i go through
we're going to spend a whole hour
talking about this on thursday so i hope
you're going to join me
and we talked about salsa i do love
salsa dancing that's me
doing a flip with uh my dance partner
and if you guys are interested in
joining tonight nine o'clock
is that legal in malaysia
is that legal i don't know you tell me i
hope so looks good to me
i hope so find me after the conference
find me after the session i'd be i'd
love to go with you guys if you're doing
salsa
and believe hey everyone evan carmichael
thank you very much
fantastic